the model-based embedded in robotic
systems group at MIT is collaborating
with the Jet Propulsion Laboratory at
Caltech on a project that will enable
astronauts to safely work with robots in
an easy and intuitive way one example of
such a robot is athlete a vehicle
developed at JPL that will support
robotic and human missions on the
surface of the Moon athlete is capable
of rolling or walking over extremely
rough or steep terrain and can load
transport manipulate and deposit
payloads to any desired sites of
interest previously robots have been
simple enough to be controlled through
teleoperation or direct commanding
however more complex robots like athlete
or the Vecna bear battlefield robot have
too many degrees of freedom for direct
teleoperation or commanding to be
practical we've developed a different
control paradigm that incorporates
verbal commands shared written
instructions and demonstration by
example to enable more efficient
interaction these modes of communication
occur naturally to humans during
collaborative tasks here is an example
of a common sense written plan where the
human and athlete work together to
collect rock samples for analysis the
instructions include descriptions of
both the humans tasks and athletes tasks
a key challenge to executing Castes is
grounding terms like pickup into athlete
motions we reduce time and effort
required to do this by teaching actions
through demonstration we use an
interface device called track developed
by the distributed robotics lab at MIT
to tele operate the robot through each
desired activity several times here
we're teaching athlete the tournament
pickup by showing athlete how to pick up
an object without hitting the box
based on the demonstrated motions our
learning algorithm generalizes from the
examples a set of motions that will
likely achieve the action of pickup this
is compactly encoded in a representation
we call a probabilistic flow tube once
athlete learns the activity it can
autonomously execute the corresponding
nominal trajectory the learned flow to
represents flexibility in the motions
the robot can choose to perform enabling
it for example to recover from
disturbances the width of the flow tube
indicates areas with more or less
flexibility after athlete knows how to
perform each of its tasks individually
it can collaborate with a human to
execute the written plan together we
have developed an executive that allows
athlete to make decision
at runtime to improve the likelihood of
successfully completing the plan
specifically athlete schedules the start
times and durations of each activity
with flexibility while ensuring that
Linds synchronize successfully this
allows it to react appropriately to the
human and still perform the actions
correctly we demonstrated our
capabilities by integrating them with
the athlete prototype at JPL and by
showing a human and athlete cooperating
to complete this task first the human
attaches a gripper to athletes left limb
the executives time stamps this activity
duration when the person is done so it
can accommodate changes in the humans
activities
now athlete is moving the gripper near
the rock and preparation to pick it up
this complex motion was learned using
the techniques described earlier since
athlete can't sense the precise location
of the rock the person can assist
athlete by fine-tuning the gripper
location through voice commanding
forward
next the human attaches have been to
athletes right limb the gripper closes
on the rock to pick it up at this point
both limbs move in position to drop the
rock into the box
finally athlete stores the box for
transport which is the end goal of the
plan in the future we plan to
demonstrate these capabilities with more
complex plans that involve a human
safely coordinating with multiple robots
engineers at JPL are currently
developing the next generation of
athlete robots called triathlete in
which each robot has three wins and can
coordinate together to transport
habitats and perform more complex
manipulation tasks in the future we aim
to show humans working safely in the
same environment as the triathletes in
order to support future operation on the
moon funding for this task was provided
through the JPL strategic university
research partnership program and the
national defense science and engineering
graduate fellowship